the question for each of you is perhaps
especially when you're portraying an
actor that you have someone who's a real
person versus a character that whom you
can really build from the ground up how
different is that process well in the
case of Gloria of course I got to watch
her films and having all of those great
movies and some not so great which was
also fascinating to watch and to watch
how she evolved and so that was actually
really helpful but of course I also felt
a great responsibility that I didn't
want to do a caricature or an imitation
of her but also I wanted to feel like
you had a sense of oh yeah that's that
woman that was in those films but she's
at a different stage of her life but
there once she stopped making movies she
also did quite a bit of television and
she made some not-so-great movies I
watched those two so that was very
helpful but knowing you know you fall in
love with a character when you play them
you want to do I wanted to do her
justice and I wanted to also do the
story justice what's so beautiful about
the book is how impressionistic it is
and economical it is and he actually
leaves most things out it's not a
biography at all so you don't really
hear about her life you don't hear about
her films or her complicated personal
life which she had had before she met
Peter it's so tasteful it's a beautiful
and just absolutely like you said
unbelievable story the fact that she
would end up in Liverpool with this
family
the out-of-sequence storytelling seemed
like it was a coil that was getting
tighter and tighter to bring about that
dramatic dynamo is that what it felt
like as you were doing all of those
scenes and moving back and forth in time
I think that when the movie is as the
movie is the relationship you know so
trying to chart the trajectory of how
you're gonna play all those scenes and
hoping that we're getting the you know
getting the gray areas of a relationship
is and all those scenes across of course
the shooting schedule doesn't care about
any of that stuff so we literally was
saying goodbye in the taxi on day 2
of the shoe I was just you know it's
mental I think we were doing the Romeo
and Juliet scene on day four or five you
know that's supposed to have that scene
is supposed to span a three and a half
years of them being together of you know
falling in love and breaking apart and
not seeing each other in that now
learning she's sick all of that you know
you have to try and prepare I mean I
suppose that's the access job but it was
very challenging I mean I love what Paul
McGuigan our director brought to this in
terms of his the theatricality of
elevating the material using glorious
films I'll be kind of abstractly and
paying homage to some of those movies
with all the back projection that you
see in physical sets that rotated and
moved around and we moved from one you
know year to another year or one
location to another and all that stuff I
think it's really heightened the story
and added to it give it's kind of
cinematic touch but it was certainly
challenging what was Paul McGuigan like
as a director was that the loose reins
approach and or was he he was very loose
friend
yeah I mean I think he trusted his
actors which is that's the thrill of
working is when you feel that you trust
the director they trust you and you're
willing to test each other and so much
of the scenes me and Annette kind of
going toe-to-toe with one another and he
just kind of let us go and do it he and
I he I know we were with him recently
and he was talking about it so he
certainly said that a number of times
that what he was doing he was watching
us and let us do letting us do what we
wanted to do
having said that he also had a very
specific way he approached the story and
the style of the movie which I really
like it's not a naturalistic movie it
has a kind of heightened reality to it
and that was Paul's idea it was his idea
to have that scene where you see it from
two different points of view the big
fight and when they break up and all of
that that was that was very much Paul's
idea and his approach so but from an
acting standpoint totally he really let
us let us do what you know what we
wanted to do and we felt very free and
he's also I mean I really like
his taste I like the way he uses the
camera you don't feel self doesn't the
camera doesn't call attention to itself
the way he's showing you what's
happening he's I just like that approach
and also very often he's not explicit in
what in the way he's shooting which I
also I like that a little bit about the
dynamic with the family with Julie
Walters and you know the the the
screaming angry brother who I a couple
of times I had a hard time understanding
I thought live the Liverpudlian of the
Beatles is long out of my head so I had
to learn how John Lennon talks all over
again well the first thing that I've
been reunited with Julie waters since
our first movie that we did together all
those years ago so it was very special
for me to to get to work with her again
I didn't know just how beloved she is I
mean I said I certainly I did but I I
work with her as a kid i that wasn't the
kind of thing I was really paying
attention to trying to figure out how to
be an actor I still and most of the time
but but uh but this experience with
those 17 years lead and now walking onto
the set just seeing how the entire crew
would they relate to her like she is a
relative of this she puts everyone at
immediate comfort she can crack a joke
and then do a serious scene and a
heartbeat
you know she's wonderful also when we
got the bunch of those actors together
Julie Steven and Kenneth who plays my
father their scenes just came alive it's
so easy there were the scenes that we
just didn't need to worry about it was
just everyone knew right it's
working-class England kitchen sink scene
and we're all kind of really good at
that because we're all from those kinds
of places and from those kinds of towns
and those were some of the easiest
things most fun scenes to shoot by the
way it's Stephen Graham who plays my
brother mostly known for being tough guy
actor playing very kind of criminal type
parts reduced to a nervous schoolboy the
day that he met Julie Walters for the
first time she has that effect on people
you talked about the sense of
responsibility to Gloria Grahame and and
what this film conveyed the fragility
and the vulnerability but the the
strength and that gallantry - did you -
Jamie feel some responsibility and what
what you would like
people to take away from this film
thinking about your character and
thinking about Gloria Grahame as well
certainly enormous responsibility I mean
whenever you get to play someone who is
still around and is sharing their life
story with you and looks to you to do
them and their story justice of course
there's this heightened sense of I hope
I get this right I don't fail them you
know but I have to say Peter is is all
the pressure that was applied I applied
to myself because Peters so lovely and
so wonderful he was genuinely so excited
that I was playing him he really was
which then to be fair made me feel even
more nervous cuz I oh no he's even happy
that I'm doing it like he's actually
excited about it you know I want people
to go you know there are good decent
people out there you know these people
who you know Liverpool is a very
specific town they wear their heart on
their sleeve very much like um you know
the people of Boston it's a night it's
an identity based place they lead with
that and they take care of one another
and they love each other and Peter is
certainly one of those people you know
the movies about these very special
people who come into our lives and they
change us in our lives forever and you
know we're always trying to kind of
understand it and make sense of them and
in many ways they don't leave us you
know and and still now I've done many
interviews with Peter recently and to
this day he's still looking out for her
he's still protecting her in some ways
he is her guardian you know it's a love
story it's about its love in its purest
form you know it transcends so many
things I think this love story and I
just hope that people are affected by
that because that was the thing for him
you know in his life this is the most
meaningful one of the most meaningful
relationships he's ever had and I hope
we just captured a fraction of that you
know why don't you please thank Annette
Bening and Jay thank you very much